[inaudible].
All right.
First off,
king,
we just did something that we've never done on this.
We stopped for a moment so that Alexis could bring you a chocolate shake in the
middle of the show.
Normally,
normally someone with diabetes and heart should not have a chocolate milk.
However,
I've lost weight and I don't know why they say it comes with aging.
I have,
I try to have a daily milkshake to not lose anymore.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's a little call back to Brooklyn,
right?
Oh yeah.
We had malteds too where they put Maltin.
Yeah,
the candy store.
There's no candy stores anymore.
There's no case.
Well,
now they've got like,
you know Beverly Hills Super Deluxe Fan by a candy eye.
Candy.
I put a jukebox and you sit in.
I have agreements.
Yeah.
Well let's talk a little bit about age.
I guess it's a little weird to talk about.
At some level.
You are 84 85 in November.
Okay,
so you didn't believe it.
My father died at 46 I've had every known disease.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe I'm this age.
What does it,
what does it feel like?
I mean you've,
you've had a couple of heart attacks.
Are these your diabetes?
A couple of things and you're still here.
You're doing your thing,
you're out and about every morning I bump into you half the time I think that,
uh,
it's,
the reason I'm around is that I have a purpose.
I,
I'm amazed that people who retire as Milton Berle told me once when I asked him,
are you going to retire?
And he said to what would I do if I get up in the morning?
I had nothing to do.
That's terrible.
So I have a place to go to follow my profession.
That's wonderful.
If you can keep that going,
I'll probably die on the air or someone else.
What would you like?
You really want to increase my youtube views right now came from,
yeah.
What would you like your obituary to read?
And I said oldest man who ever lived passed away today
in his sleep with a smile on his face.
But you still get a kick out of everything.
I know it.
So wait,
just real quick,
tell,
tell everybody a little bit about,
you have these breakfasts with your old crew.
Well,
some of them have passed away.
The guys I grew up with in Brooklyn,
but we have a crew of about five or six.
We meet every day at different places and we attained to David.
We solve the problems in the world today and we solve the rack
audience.
No worries about Iraq.
The table solve the closely through jokes.
We do all the jokes and we talked about people getting in arguments.
We talk about Israel,
we talk hearings,
who's this,
what's this senator doing,
what she doing?
And then we also discuss Sinatra and old time musicians and who's doing what and
what Barbara Streisand make on her last tour.
And so we never know where the discussion is going and that's the wonderful,
and when you were going to have friends from childhood,
two of mine have passed away,
but I still have two others.
The best thing about it is I'm not Larry King.
I'm Larry to soccer.
That was my birth name and they're very happy for me.
But I'm still a
button,
the button on your shirt,
you know what I mean?
They,
they don't treat you like anything different.
What's it like as somebody of a certain age now where you know,
you just mentioned you've lost some childhood friends.
Your brother passed away just last year or so months ago.
Yeah.
Um,
just watching life turn in that way.
That's the sad Sinatra told me once.
The saddest thing about aging is your friends go before you.
I didn't want my brother to die before me.
He was your younger brother,
right?
Yeah,
he was 80.
I'm,
yeah,
he was 80.
Yeah.
Is Hard.
It's um,
cause I don't believe in an afterlife.
I'm not religious.
You think this is it that baby.
That's it.
I've never,
I've interviewed thousands of people,
people who said they've seen death and all this,
I don't buy it.
I may be a little,
I just,
it just makes no sense to me that Lincoln is up there or that there's someone up
there looking down on me.
I am,
I went to my grandchildren's,
they're twins,
boy and a girl.
So they had a bot and a bar Mitzvah.
And for the first time in ages,
I read from the Old Testament
that God,
he's the work.
Huh?
Son of a bitch cheese.
Did he hate it?
Rocked my enemies.
Lou Out to show me one good pen.
My God,
believe in me.
Above me.
He was vain.
Incredible.
He was a Donald Trump before there was a Donald Trump believe in me above all
others.
I am the,
I can't believe it.
So when I read that
I couldn't believe it,
so I can't buy it.
I've interviewed all the great religious leaders except pope.
Yeah.
I've never been convinced.
So when you,
when you've sat down,
I mean you've sat down with everybody from the Dalai Lama across the board with
Billy Graham was a friend.
Yeah.
So when you sat down with them,
even if you don't believe it,
did you feel that some of them were able to get something out of belief?
I believe they believe,
unless there was some phone,
these,
you know,
sending $10 and I'll send you a little cross.
I don't buy any of that.
Sat Down with some of those guys do.
Oh yeah.
Jerry Falwell since as George Burns once said,
when he played God,
it's a great movie,
great movie.
And he gathers all the religious leaders and he calls in a Jerry Falwell type
and the fall type.
Go See,
call me in.
First goes up to his room,
sits down,
and God says to him,
why don't you sell shoes?
So I never,
I never bought that part,
but I,
I liked Billy Graham,
respected them.
Billy Graham thought I was very spiritual.
And do I believe in Billy is with Jesus now?
No.
But bill,
he believed that he believed he was going to Jesus.
He had not been,
have a fear of death.
He had a fear of being in a plane that's gone down to crash.
But he didn't fear death.
I fear I don't,
I don't.
I'm like Woody Allen.
I don't fear it.
I just don't want to be there.
Uh,
I can't go.
So my wife believes I respect believer's.
See,
when I approached an interview with Billy Graham,
I respect him.
I asked him the best questions I could ask,
like,
why do you need to stay at the Fontainebleau or as I've called her,
Lenny Bruce Timm,
any person who's got a calling from the Lord to lead the flock who has more than
one suit while someone has no clothes,
it's a copout.
And Billy Graham said,
in today's world,
you have to have more than one scene.
You have to travel.
I asked him if Christ Jesus probably had one pair of flip flop,
the crease would,
would Christ,
would he buy suits?
And he said yes,
and he would go on television.
That was the means of communication.
I mean,
that's their answer,
but he believed it.
I respected his belief,
but I'm not afraid to ask them any question if when you die,
if you believe in Jesus Christ,
you will live forever.
What happens is the Jews,
and he said,
well,
I,
I don't go into them,
but maybe at the moment of their death they accept Christ.
That's kind of a cop out.
There's always sort of another answer.
Right.
Did you ever talk to anybody,
either religious or otherwise,
that you felt had some sort of special insight into something?
Well,
I have this doctor on who was convinced that he had died,
visited what the world of afterlife was,
and then his life was saved.
He was a recognized doctor,
knew what disease he had.
I threw it up to a vivid imagination and he got a bestselling book out of it.
People want to believe,
you know,
I wished that I had faith that I could make.
It's called the leap of faith.
You can't prove it.
So it's a leap of faith.
Now we have faith in a lot of things.
You get on an airplane,
you have the faith that that airplane company hired a licensed pilot I punched.
You have some core of belief that you think that you,
if you jump out of the 10th floor of a building,
you're not gonna make it so you don't Trump
the people who have that faith who go beyond.
I just think they've got a great crutch,
Greg Crutch to know you're going somewhere,
but at the end,
do you think it matters if they,
if they live a good life and you live a good life?
First of all,
they never to know.
Yeah.
If they go somewhere they were right.
If they don't,
they don't know cause they did.
So they got a good deal going.
They really have a good deal.
I don't have an Amish.
If I've got an afterlife,
I'll be shocked.
Yeah,
but you'll be doing this.
Oh,
I will.
Absolutely.
Or maybe you'll be playing baseball up there.
I'm not that good.
That good.
Um,
let's talk a little bit about politics.
You mentioned Trump.
We did about 40 minutes.
His name didn't even come up once.
First Time in American conversation that any two people had a conversation for
40 minutes and the name Trump than not.
That's one thing he's done.
I'll bet you everyone in America at one time today said the name Trump.
Everybody.
Is there anyone else that in the years that you've been doing this,
that you saw just that effect?
He's the only president that I've known for 40 years.
I met the other presidents some before they became President Barack Obama,
George Bush,
Bill Clinton.
But they were in the political sphere.
But Trump is the only one that was my friend before Trump and I went to the
Superbowl together.
Can you talk about I fathers of the year together?
Is that right?
1995 he had his kids and my kids as a wall of his story.
We got trophies.
Um,
I went to see Marla maples and her Broadway show.
I went with Trump.
I stayed at hotels when I had some minor surgery in New York.
He took my wife out to dinner the night before.
He caught me at every hotel they own,
put me in a suite at the plaza when he owned the plaza.
But one thing we always knew about Trump,
he was a character and he lied.
Now he,
he almost lined by,
it's snowing out when it wasn't,
you know,
he'd be on my show and say highest rating it.
And it was all about him,
but he was a character and it was fun.
And he could be very nice and generous.
Okay.
I had all those qualities,
but he was a character.
I mean,
he would call up the New York Post with a different name and tell them stories
about Donald Trump's so we can get on page six.
That was his goal,
but precedent.
Precedent.
Are you kidding?
Anybody,
any of us who knew him ago?
First,
he was a moderate
to central Democrat,
supported Hillary Clinton.
Loved Hillary Clinton.
Thought she was a great senator.
He wanted single payer health care.
He didn't care about abortion.
Come on,
evangelicals.
I don't think Donald ever read a book,
but he's,
but he was a friendly character to be around a wonderful guest.
A lot of fun.
Fly off the top,
but precedent.
Precedent.
So what do you make about what happened here?
Like I have no idea where Hillary was a bad candidate.
A wonderful person.
I Know Hillary very well.
Great sense of humor.
Sad.
I don't know what her,
she didn't go to Wisconsin.
Did you get a different Hillary when you would into her interview her publicly?
This is what a lot of her is that she's very friendly and open.
The one on one.
She's good.
Yeah.
In front of an audience.
She's not,
she's not a good move.
She's running for something now wish I went to a young kippah service where she
was the speaker.
She was terrific.
She wasn't running from anything.
She was a senator from New York and damn good center.
Uh,
she ran a horrendous campaign and she was not a good campaign.
I thought she won the debates,
but it almost didn't matter.
Trump became,
went from,
got elected with that first question in the first republican debate when he was
asked about women and did he ever call women pigs and he said only Rosie
O'donnell and he sat in the middle of all the Republicans.
Why did they see them in the middle was just four on one side.
Fournier did you really think at the end from that moment that I thought he
would ignite something,
but I thought he was dead when he said that thing about McCain isn't a hero.
Certainly when he got off the bus with Billy Bush,
I thought that was over,
but his base doesn't care if evangelicals can put aside his personal life,
he'll never lose them.
He'll level.
It's,
it's,
I've never lived in weird at times.
I mean this is the weirdest time to every day.
Yeah.
There's a story.
Does this truly in all your years,
does this right now feel like a truly,
truly unique time?
Because people ask me that.
I'll have to come like events.
I do and I think the answer's yes.
Although you always think when you're living it,
but of course it's your neck.
Do you believe that somebody said one day to see what Lincoln Center to hear
what Roseville dig last night,
to see the speech that caught him mean to you?
When was that weird?
No,
they didn't do weird things.
They were president that I remember.
I was in the White House interviewing George Bush and Barbara Bush said to me,
Larry suspenders,
the White House,
you know,
she was in the White House's.
This place is now.
I wonder what it's like in their carrier.
The guy writes the op Ed piece in the New York Times.
Mike God,
the Woodward Book,
Fascinating Book.
We living in those times would would've gone believe it,
but I could see as you talk about it,
here's a glimmer in your eye,
like there's something exciting about this.
Do you think that that's in a weird way,
the,
the good part of this,
even if it's kind of helter skelter now and I'm glad I'm not alone,
CNN,
no,
I wouldn't want to be doing panels every day and Trump all the time.
I don't want to do that.
That's not the whole world.
Trump's not the whole world.
He thinks he's the whole.
How,
how important do you think
politics actually is?
Because I think now there's maybe what I'm realizing now is that this is really
about culture.
What we're fighting right now,
this,
this battle that seems to be in points about culture.
It's about what do we really care about?
What do we like,
not just about the ins and outs and machinations of
too much of America is still prejudiced,
Latino's,
blacks.
That still runs through a lot of us.
In my opinion,
people voting against their own self interest.
No,
let's,
I wanted to face it with something.
Obamacare is working for a lot of people.
You don't hear many complaints about people who are under it and getting good
medical care.
I'm not sure they'll ever do away with it.
Just those,
those kinds of facts are sort of bothers me when I see that.
Why we still have prejudice in America and appeal to it.
I mean,
Trump,
even his defendant would say he appeals to what?
What?
What did we need a,
we need a wall.
Do you think,
do you think that's a play by him?
I mean,
for all the years that you knew him,
did you think he was racist or that this is,
I never thought he was racist.
I think he was opportunity.
He was,
he took advantage of a situation.
So we used to say he wasn't smart.
He wasn't book smart.
I bet at at school he got gentlemen see
the big influences in his life or Roy Cohn who I knew very well and his father
and they were bad influences.
I mean Rog Roy Cohn was,
I liked him because he was peculiar,
but he was waiting for the people that don't know who write on it.
He was a bad guy.
He was part of the McCarthy era and
angels in America had,
he played a part in that play.
Uh,
and he was affected by that.
And so I never,
I never thought he was a racist,
but his narcissism was beyond belief.
I in every other sentence,
I did this,
I did that.
I'm the greatest president we've ever had.
How often think you say that?
How could you say that?
Okay,
so if you were sitting down with him,
I would say Donald,
why?
I spoke to them everyday during the camp,
but not every day,
once a week during the campaign,
he knew I was voting for Hillary,
but we were friends and he would call me.
What do you think it is?
I'm the one that is,
what do you think of that?
I got this.
What do you think it is something.
I'm going to do an interview with the New York Times,
you know,
the guy,
should I do this?
And then when he was elected,
I never heard from him again.
[inaudible]
do you think we can get out of this polarization that we seem to be in?
So if we're in this unique time right now and crazy time,
how's it going to change?
You know,
we don't have,
uh,
forcefully to,
it might be Bloomberg
to lead us.
We need someone
to leave this out.
We need Gary Cooper,
maybe George Clooney in the modern society.
I'm a king.
George Clooney.
A Bright Jenny is bright.
Uh,
George Clooney wouldn't be very popular.
Women's vote
smart as a whip.
Okay.
What does that tell you though?
If we need to go to celebrities,
do you think maybe we're just in there in this,
that's what it is,
is that's the internet.
That's the world we live in.
Yeah.
I like Georgia.
I'd vote for him.
But do you think we can get out of this,
this thing where they say a medical always comes through everything?
George will,
who's will come very anti.
Trump believes we can find the way.
Again,
America is a way of finding a way.
I hope so.
I hope I'm around to see it.
Um,
but right now,
and you know when in my early,
I could name every Senator [inaudible] 10,
20 years ago.
Every shot.
Yeah.
And got Ya.
Orrin Hatch and Ted Kennedy were great friends,
sponsored bills together.
Hatch did his eulogy
that,
that wouldn't exist today.
Okay.
That we have today.
The thing is so bad,
when Obama nominated his guy for the Supreme Court,
I shouldn't forget his name.
Uh,
and they never brought it up.
Now of course it,
uh,
we'll get it.
We'll get it or not.
When,
when,
when we nominate people like that who was pretty much middle of the road.
Oh,
garland.
Merrick.
Garland.
Yeah.
If I were to Democrats now and they take the Senate,
I would hold up any appointment until they can have a president and first person
out of point would be married calling who deserve to be on that court.
Yeah.
So this is just both of them playing politics to them.
But will we have a chance?
I,
I don't see it coming.
You know when Merrick Garland was nominated,
for example,
Orrin Hatch,
before he knew they would delay it,
said he's a great man
and then it becomes
party over country,
party over country.
Sad.
We'll let you think.
It's going to change.
I think that the outrage machine that we're running on right now,
I think it can only last for so long,
so I think it can either blow up into something much worse and I don't even know
what I mean by that,
but I think things would actually get much worse and some of this would actually
spill over into violence or what my hope is,
and I think this is the more a realistic option,
is that the outrage will start running out of steam,
like a car running out of gas and that from that somebody who,
whether it maybe if you're a Clooney or whoever else,
it is just such a decent human being,
a Bloomberg or something else will come back and decency will be appreciated
because I don't think this outrage thing can run forever.
It's too,
it's too mentally exhausting.
it's physically,
yeah.
Was a decent man.
I've known for years that Joe Biden,
nobody dislikes him.
Wonderful father.
And a third is a great senator.
[inaudible]
great vice president.
If he were a little younger,
can you imagine he'd be,
what,
82 or something because she can't dislike them.
You want to be VP?
No,
I couldn't take the cut in pay.
All right,
let's,
let's finish up with some big picture.
It's a big picture stuff.
Looking back,
is there anything you would've done differently?
The rear,
when I got married as much,
I would have gone national sooner.
I had the talent,
but I was a big fish in a smaller pond in Miami and I liked that I'd radio
television,
cop column in the Miami Herald.
You know,
everybody knew me and Miami.
I never sent a tape to New York.
Right.
I should have.
I would have liked to have gone national sooner just just to have more success.
Earlier you had to appeal to more people because I had something,
I knew I was good.
I knew I was good at what I did and I,
I didn't really get well known till my fifties and I think it could have
happened in the thirties I'm not any better than I was in the thirties I'm not
better today than I was when I was in my late twenties I was all see,
I always was curious.
I always let my ego at the door or was there short questions,
always got really interested in the guests.
That never changed.
Sometimes someone will play me a tape that they had for 30 years ago,
stole me.
Yeah,
I'm still,
they're still asking questions.
I think the first time I interviewed you,
I asked you something about the ego component relative to,
to interviewing and your answer.
I loved it and I,
I've really tried to incorporate it in what I do,
which is,
you said the show was called Larry King tonight.
My ego was already stroke.
Yeah,
I'll be there tomorrow.
My motto,
it's a good model.
David could be,
your motto could be anybody's model.
If Donald Trump had this model,
we would be a better country.
This is my model.
I never learned anything when I was talking.
Think about it.
Now I may impart things to people.
I may pick some knowledge,
but I am what I'm doing.
Anything
when I'm talking,
it feels like a privilege in a way,
right?
When you have somebody great across from you and you get the damn was this,
I'm telling you,
this hour of my life is a privilege.
Oh,
to be on the Rubin report.
To be part of what?
By the way,
since is a report,
do I get a grade?
You will be graded at the,
Oh,
trust me,
the youtube commentors they're going when we get youtube comments as they're
going to see.
I don't have the will with all the hottie Larry King.
That is the last thing I wanted to impart on you.
All right,
final question.
Here we go.
What's it all about?
I've asked you this.
I've asked you some version of this many times every day,
my friend.
What's it all about and what does it all mean?
What does it mean
a hundred years from today?
Who's going to care?
Right?
John Lowenstein once hit a grand slam home run for the Orioles to beat the
Yankees,
and it was crowd went crazy.
Someone said,
John,
how does it feel?
And he said,
100 million Chinese don't give a damn.
What does it all mean?
The answer is I don't know.
All right,
my friend.
Well,
despite the fact that you did not wear suspenders today,
I did not.
I want it to be totally casual with you.
This true.
This is what it's about.
What I,
what we just did for the last hour.
Thank you David.
Thank you.
My pleasure.
And thank you for the milkshake.
Alright,
you guys can check out Larry on Aura TV and follow him on Twitter acting things.